( intro music )
South Africa has one of
the most sophisticated
and extensive networks of
marine reserves on our planet.
Home!
My home. I get to go home.
You know, after ten
years on the road
and I was gone sometimes
300 days a year.
I got a bit tired
of not being home.
So, the next story
that I proposed to
National Geographic was actually
a story about my backyard.
I wanted to actually
tell the story about
our network of marine reserves.
Marine birds normally don't
feature all that much
when we talk about
marine reserves.
However, this is
what happens when
they don't feature
in management.
This is a picture that I
took on slide from 2003.
It's a place called
Malgas Island.
And I went back there for
the article last year
and this is what I found.
Major decrease in
nesting numbers because
even though this
island is protected,
the fishing grounds are not.
The sardines and
the anchovies that
these birds eat are overfished.
So, a lot of these
youngsters die on the nest.
There's a place called
Mercury Island in Namibia.
And this is the centerpiece of
the Namib Island Marine Reserve.
And here for the first
time, people are trying to
connect the nesting grounds
and the feeding grounds
of these birds together.
Mercury Island has stable
population of Cape Gannets.
You know, Bank Cormorants
the most endangered
marine bird in Africa
stable population,
only place.
Penguins,
African Penguins.
They can't fly, so what
happens is they can only swim
a certain amount of distance
before they have to
go back and feed their chicks.
So, they are the first ones
to abandon and starve.
Here...
these guys are not
starving, are they?
( audience laughter )
Penguins heading out to sea.
You know, this looks like a
really calm and beautiful scene.
It's, you know, sunny and
it's just this sort of
an idyllic place
and this is what it looks like
when you're trying to
take this picture.
Water is about five degrees
and you're in this rock pool
and you're surrounded by
massive Atlantic Ocean waves.
Assistant:
We got a big one!
There's my assistant warning
me there's a big wave coming.
So, I swim away from the
picture, trying to save myself.
( sound of waves )
Assistant:
Okay. False alarm.
( audience laughter )
So I just try to swim back again
and this goes on for hours.
And then he misses
the flipping wave.
And here come
the penguins.
( audience laughter )
I'm going, "What's going...
you're supposed to be there."
It's a little bit
dangerous there because
if you get washed out
to sea, you're done!
There's another wave coming,
I'm shooting and again...
( waves crashing on the rocks )
Anyway, you know
most marine reserves in
Africa were actually
they work great for
bio-diversity.
Except they were imposed
on the local communities.
And so, even though,
you know, they...
you know, biologically and
scientifically they're amazing,
most local people do not
benefit from these reserves.
Thus there's, you know,
high levels of poaching
and there's actually a
danger of these reserves
being opened up to fishing,
because they serve no benefit
to the local people who
live next to them.
And, a developing country
like South Africa
you kind of have to marry
the needs of
bio-diversity and people
if you want to have any
chance of being sustainable.
So, I was looking for
a few examples where
people and bio-diversity
coexisted together...
you know, happily.
This is Ponta on the
Mozambique-South African border.
This is the only marine
national park in Africa.
And here, both sides of
the border are protected
and these dolphins spend half
their lives in Mozambique,
and half their life
in South Africa.
And now, because of this new
arrangement of conservation
their entire habitat
is protected.
But the reason I went
there is because
they have a really
interesting perspective
on how they integrate people
into the marine environment.
The rangers instead
of, you know,
doing anti-poaching patrols
and arresting people,
they built a school.
And they're teaching kids.
The philosophy there is
we first have to give
the local residents a benefit
and the benefit
here is education.
And this is a little video
of them learning Portuguese.
( children reciting Portuguese
vowels and sounds )
They also hold
immunization clinic
and a nurse comes
out once a month.
The adults love this service.
Kids not so much.
( audience laughter )
This little guy was not
a happy chap, but again
you know, this is one
of those great examples
where, you know, before
enforcing regulation
they wanted to give the
community benefits.
Further north in Mozambique,
you know, Vamizi Island
again an interesting
case-study where you have
a luxury resort and a fishing
community on one island
and together they
agree to protect
half of their coral
reef from all fishing
and for last ten years.
And now the fishermen,
the reserve is so good
it's actually exporting
fish biomass
into the fishing
zones on the outside
And now these guys are having a
better catch than ever before.
So, again, you know,
there are ways
to marry bio-diversity
and people.
And this is what has to
happen in South Africa
if these reserves are gonna
have any hope in surviving
over the next five or ten years.
To end this evening
I want to kind of go back
right to the beginning.
This was one of my favorite
books as a child.
"Under the Red Sea"
by Dr. Prof. Hans Hass.
He was an Austrian diving
pioneer and biologist.
And you know, one of my biggest
wishes as a kid was to
sort of, you know, be in one of
you know, in the situations
that he found himself.
And, you know, putting
this presentation together
I came across this image,
and I went, "Sheesh.
I've already had
those experiences."
So, you know, full circle, you
know 12 years later and...
thank you all so
much for coming.
( applause )